support for think fast talk smart comes
from stanford continuing studies
stanford continuing studies offers over
150 online classes on a wide range of
topics from art history to ai wellness
to writing as well as courses on
business and communication
fall registration opens august 16th and
is open to all adult learners everywhere
most classes start the week of september
20th learn more at
continuingstudies.stanford.edu
imagine what it would be like to be at
your best every time you communicated
alert
focused engaged and with minimal fear
today using research from neuroscience
we'll explore how you can hack your
communication to maximize your impact
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
i am really looking forward to speaking
with andrew huberman who is a professor
in the neurobiology department at
stanford university's school of medicine
andrew's research focuses on
understanding the brain mechanisms
controlling anxiety cognition and
performance under stress
additionally andrew works diligently to
bring neuroscience research to the
public through his teaching his videos
and his hubermann lab podcast which
needs to be in everyone's playlist
thanks for being here andrew shall we
get started
delighted to be here
like me i know you're fascinated by fear
and its impact
as we all know communicating in front of
others in high stakes situations can
certainly involve fear
from a neurologic point of view what's
going on what happens to our voice our
speech and our hand movements when we
get nervous
yeah so when we get nervous
we are entering a state which is
perfectly natural but reflects
one station along what's called the
autonomic continuum
and really the autonomic continuum can
be conceptualized as a continuum between
states of very high alertness think
maximum excitement or fear all the way
down to deep sleep
so our states of mind and body
are not discrete
entities they are along this continuum
this autonomic continuum so when we are
excited or we are nervous
we have a number of physiological
responses that are
purely autonomic meaning they're purely
automatic
the most important thing to realize is
that it is a continuum it has some
features that are autonomic meaning
automatic
and
that
there's no
difference between the physiological
response to something that you're
excited about and something that you're
nervous about or that you're dreading
and so there's an additional component
there that we need to consider but the
the most important thing of above
all and i guess if people are going to
take away anything from our conversation
today it's that despite these responses
being automatic
there are direct control points
through which we can control the
autonomic nervous system meaning that we
can dial down the level of alertness or
increase the level of calmness those
actually turn out to be two different
things so while it's called the
autonomic nervous system and the
autonomic continuum it's a bit of a
misnomer because there are two specific
levers or entry points that we all have
from birth
that require essentially no learning
there's you have to know what they are
but that will allow people to control
voice level of alertness level of
shaking in their hands so it's a quite
remarkable system in that it has this
asymmetry autonomic on the one hand but
with very powerful entry points for
control on the other i want to get back
to the notion that you brought up about
how we uh
experience the physiological arousal
that we get you said it in some cases
it's due to anxiety and fear in other
cases it's due to excitement you know
part of that i think has to do with how
we label what we're experiencing and i
know that there's some research from my
academic field that says one way to help
manage anxiety is just to work on how
you perceive the physiological symptoms
that you're having so if you say hey
even though my heart rate's going up i'm
getting a little sweaty and shaky it's
because i'm excited to share the
information i'm sharing versus oh my
goodness everybody's looking at me and
i'm feeling nervous so part of it i
think has to do with how we frame the
situation is that ring true
absolutely when we are in a state of
alertness whether
because of excitement or fear
the
sympathetic division of the autonomic
nervous system let's just call the
alertness system
deploys a hormone from our adrenal
glands adrenaline and it deploys the
equivalent chemical in the brain where
it's called epinephrine it's actually
the same chemically identical structure
but called two different things because
neuroscientists and physiologists like
to make things complicated
um not simple
but the the role of adrenaline
epinephrine
is to create agitation in the body
and to create focus in the mind
and this is an important concept because
that agitation makes it harder to be
still which is sort of a duh right
that's the definition of agitation
but it was designed for to move us to
physically move us so that we would be
biased toward ambulation or bias toward
um shifting what from one position to a
new one and so one of the toughest
things for many people is to tolerate
that level of adrenaline or alertness
when they have to be still the simplest
example i can give this that i think
most people will be familiar with is if
um in the days where we uh congregated
in person there's this traditional
practice of going around the room
and introducing yourself and saying
something about what you do and
most people actually find that to be
very stressful especially if they toward
the end of the line now why would that
be right most people know their name and
can say their name most people know what
they do and can say that it's anything
but a high stress circumstance and
occasionally there's some social
pressure where if someone's very funny
before us or they say something uh in a
particularly nice way then we feel like
some additional pressure to do that as
well but it really has more to do with
the fact that when we're in a room
listening to somebody we can uh we're
comfortable with the fact that we're not
going to speak or walk or do much and we
could just sit there and write or listen
or text or grow or whatever it is we
have to do as
we are called on to say something
the reason it's easier to do early in
the line is because
we are holding on to a reverbatory
circuit there are circuits in our brain
that anticipate action and prepare us
for action and the longer we keep that
in check the more challenging it becomes
when we are with trying to withhold
action but we're preparing for action
there's a lot of re reverberatory excuse
me active activity in our nervous system
and it feels like stress getting ready
to go up to the podium is tough when we
get up to the podium many people
including myself find that if we rock
back and forth a little bit or we can
engage some movement in our body
suddenly we start to relax and that's
because a drug adrenaline slash
epinephrine was designed to move us and
it wasn't designed to move us in
response to
incoming large predators it was but
that's not its primary function its
primary function was to move us from
whatever position we're into a new
position sometimes towards things
sometimes away from things depending on
whether or not
we want the experience or we want to
avoid the experience but the actual
inner experience what we call
interoception our perception of our
internal landscape is identical for
something that we want to approach
versus we want to move away from
absolutely identical below that from the
neck down that is
really interesting so so if you can
reframe the physiological response you
can see it very differently and i find
fascinating that that when we see
somebody who is nervous
moving one way versus the other way as
an audience member we have very
different perceptions so if somebody
steps up on a stage and then takes a
step back as they're starting to speak
it looks like they're retreating and
therefore may be nervous or shy but if
somebody actually steps forward we have
a perception that they're confident in
stepping into the challenging situation
so it's not only what we perceive it's
how the audience perceives it as well
absolutely it's it might be useful for
people to think about the the fact that
there's only three responses we can have
to any circumstance one is to stay still
one is to move forward or one is to move
back
back in 2018 a graduate student in the
neurosciences program who did her thesis
with me lindsey saleh and i published a
paper in the journal nature
lindsay discovered a brain circuit
that controls the movement toward
threats now these this isn't the kind of
movement that will get you killed this
is the kind of movement toward a uh in
an intelligent way in an adaptive way
towards something that in this case an
animal or a person wants to do but feels
a tremendous amount of of autonomic
arousal of stress and nervousness about
and the the take-home message
is the following
forward movement under conditions of
anxiety or high levels of alertness aka
stress
triggers the activation of a circuit
deep in the brain that releases the
neurochemical dopamine dopamine of
course is a molecule that is
most commonly associated with a
sensation of reward
and it is released when we achieve
something that we want to achieve but
the other very interesting function of
dopamine is to increase the probability
that we will move toward similar types
of goals in the future so dopamine is
not just the molecule reward it's the
molecule of motivation and drive and so
lindsay's results have a number of
different implications but
i think if people can just conceptualize
that
the anxiety or stress response is the
same as the excitement response they
feel
different because of some top down
perception or or
verbiage that we introduced to it but
they're actually identical
physiologically and that forward
movement provided it's adaptive
um toward a goal triggers the activation
of chemicals in the brain and body that
will make the subsequent pursuit of
those same or similar goals
more likely and more pleasurable
that's really cool so so learning to
take the stage and step forward leaning
in when you're virtual can help and i
believe in some of the work of yours
that i read uh it doesn't even you don't
actually have to even physically move if
you simulate movement with your eyes you
can have a similar effect and i'd like
for you to talk about that
back in the early 80s uh someone
actually in palo alto a woman by the
name of francine shapiro as a
psychologist
developed a technique for it was
actually developed for trauma
treatment she was a psychologist did
some work at stanford but also um at a
nearby clinic and essentially
she had found
that taking walks
were was helpful for her anxiety and
stress something that everyone now i
think says okay duh but we always
thought that it was because of movement
of the body but she wanted to import
some of that
self-induced relaxation to her clinic
and she was clever enough to create this
thing that they call emdr eye movement
desensitization reprocessing which
simply involves moving the eyes from
side to side it looks a little goofy if
you see someone do it but moving the
eyes from side to side not up or down
but side to side eye movement actually
triggers we now know suppression of the
amygdala this fear center in the brain
and for years people would ask me about
emdr because i'm a vision scientist and
i work on stress and i thought it was
totally kooky and crazy and i didn't
believe any of it and i
my response was in my mind anyway was
sort of like okay take your emdr and
your magic carpet and
you know
right and uh head down head down to big
sur and let's talk later if you want to
talk science but i really i i was really
quite wrong because a couple years ago
there were no fewer than five papers
published in very high quality journals
including nature
in
mice
non-human primates and humans showing
that these lateralized eye movements
lead to suppression of this fear center
in the brain so it's a quite
long-lasting effect i it's i should just
mention if people are going to use it to
deal with actual trauma that should be
done with a real trauma
it works best for specific circumstances
like public speaking it's not great for
sort of reducing your stress about your
entire childhood or your entire um
divorce or your entire 2020. it's it's
best geared toward specific
circumstances but here's how it works
you move your eyes from side to side for
about 30 seconds which is actually quite
a long time you don't do this during the
event right but that creates a state of
reduced alertness aka stress not so much
you follow asleep in your system and
then you're able to better approach
things
with more ease and more with less
alertness i've heard you mention on your
podcast that there are two approaches to
addressing stress can you share those
with us
the two approaches are you can either
reduce your stress in real time
things like this eye movements right
before you go into a stressful event
like up on stage or hard conversation or
even if you're just experiencing anxiety
there's a breathing tool i'll share with
you in a moment that's grounded deeply
in physiology as well or
you can raise your stress threshold so
things like
ice baths running up steep mountains um
exposure therapy those are actually
designed to increase your tolerance your
cognitive tolerance for high levels of
agitation in your body increasing the
probability that you'll stay still not
say the wrong thing
um not strike anyone not lose your cool
right
so it's sort of learning to be calm in
storm or what is sometimes referred to
as being comfortable being uncomfortable
that is a distinctly different set of
practices than things like the eye
movements i described or the second
thing which is a real-time tool for
calming oneself
that my laboratory is working closely on
with david spiegel's laboratory in the
department of psychiatry which is we ask
the question what
breathing
approach is the best to calm oneself in
real time because meditation is
wonderful tm is wonderful
uh if you know if you're of drinking age
and you can tolerate it without going
into excess a nice glass of wine is also
another way to activate this
right
so is a massage so is it a dip in this
in the hot tub or a sauna sounds like
you're describing a nice date
right yeah exactly or you know we're um
remember it's called the rest and digest
system for a reason one of the most
powerful ways to shift your autonomic
nervous system to one of more calm is to
fill your gut
with
food
that then the distinction of your gut
sends signals through the vagus nerve to
a little clap set of neurons right
behind your ear called the nodos ganglia
which projects into your brain gives you
a little bit of a dopamine hit this is
well well established as well as
activating areas of the brain that are
involved in calming you down and so you
know there are a lot of ways to control
the autonomic nervous system slowly and
indirectly massage hot tub big meal
etc we're talking about real time
control fast so the best way that we
know or that and this is work that's
still in progress is to use what are
called physiological size so these were
discovered back in the 30s
turns out that when
you are stressed you are breathing less
deeply the most common the most common
advice is to take a deep breath right it
turns out that's exactly the wrong
advice oh no
exhale emphasized breathing leads to
much more rapid activation of the
calming arm of the nervous system
and the it turns out you don't just want
to exhale
you want to do a double inhale so inhale
twice through the nose so inhale through
the nose and then before you exhale
sneak in a little bit more air
and then do a long exhale and you do
this just one to three times so it's you
know inhale
inhale again even if you just sneak the
tiniest bit of air ideally the inhales
are done through the nose and then
exhale through the mouth now why does
this work
turns out
that your lungs are not just two big
bags of air
they are
billions
of little tiny sacks called the avioli
of the lungs right those little sacs are
are continue contiguous more or less
with the vasculature with the blood
supply so when you exhale you offload
carbon dioxide and a lot of the stress
responses due to elevated carbon dioxide
in the bloodstream
when if you've ever been to a kid's
party and that you're asked to blow up a
balloon and you blow on the balloon
sometimes it inflates right away but if
it doesn't you give two hard
push uh pushes with air one or two and
the same thing happens with the aviola
the lungs as we get stressed they start
to collapse
they flatten out and to reinflate them
the double inhale
brings maximal air into the area of the
lungs and then you offload the maximum
amount of carbon dioxide when you exhale
so this is very simple very fast you can
actually do it during exercise as well
so if you ever find that your heart is
pounding and you want to calm down
first thing is exhale
then maybe try the double inhale and
then exhale follow
usually at least what we find in our
studies is that within just one to three
of those cycles meaning within about
five seconds autonomic nervous system
starts to shift more towards calmness
and then if you like you can start using
your eye movements or whatever cognitive
reframing but one of the things that i
think will resonate with people and i
hope it does is that it is very hard to
control the mind with the mind when
you're stepping up to the podium and you
are nervous
you can say oh yeah that nervousness is
actually excitement and i think you know
and this is i must be really agitated
because i really want to do this and but
it in that moment of stress it's very
hard to control what's going on so under
conditions where your mind is not where
you want it
use the body to control the mind
[Music]
so you've just shared techniques for
what we can do when we're directly
experiencing anxiety what can we do to
prepare for anxiety in advance
the other thing to do is the stuff that
you do away from the podium away from
the big event or the hard conversation
and that involves deliberately taking
yourself into states
of heightened alertness
as my colleague david spiegel likes to
say it's not just about the state you
find yourself in it's how you got there
and whether or not you had anything to
do with it and what he's really saying
is that when you drive your nervous
system into a state of high alertness
and you learn to be calm there
you achieve a certain kind of superpower
such that when real life puts you into
those states without any warning and
very fast
you it's like driving in fog the first
time you do it it's scary as heck the
fifth time you do it it's still scary
but you you've been there before
and so you're now a good driver so the
way you do this it
can be of different um
you know practices but one of the best
ones is a very cold shower and trying to
stay calm for one to three minutes in a
very cold shower wow it's not something
that i like uh it's not very quiet
which is
the and there you use a protocol of
breathing that involves taking 25 to 30
deep inhales for reasons that now it
should be obvious right increase your
heart rate
and then big exhales
hyperventilating
you're hyperventilating and by the 25th
one you will be very stressed now i want
to say that if people have our panic
attack prone or anxiety attack prone
this is gonna i do not recommend this
very uncomfortable but then what you do
at the end of that 25 breaths is you
offload all your air you empty your
lungs
and then you sit
for about 15 to some people can go
longer 60 seconds or so lungs empty
and you try and feel peaceful with that
heightened level of adrenaline in your
body
now never do this near water i want to
be really clear because there is this
thing called shallow water don't even do
it in a puddle right um
because i i don't want anyone injuring
themselves or worse but if you repeat
that for two or three cycles what you
will find it's pretty remarkable there
are a lot of there's some nuance to
these practices but they all kind of
start and end with vision or breathing
right and and i love how you make them
simple for us to understand so the
things we can do in the moment or right
at uh before the moment of the anxiety
and then there are things we can do to
in essence desensitize ourselves in
advance now we are all communicating in
this virtual world these days
is there anything from your experience
of how eyes work that that would
indicate what we should do for example
people often say you need to look at the
camera so it looks like you're looking
at the person on the other end any
insight you have
about this virtual communication we all
do
huh uh okay well first of all it's a
very unnatural time because um most of
all because
we are not used to seeing a little
picture of ourselves moving while we
look at other people um everyone's
carrying a little mirror around on their
shoulder for us now in this world so
turn that off or get it out of the way
um because it will interfere with your
presence to the conversation and
um other people's perception of how
present you are the other thing that's
really important is that there's a lot
of research on gaze and eye contact and
frequency of blinking the most powerful
uh way to connect with somebody through
zoom or just in person is actually not
to stare directly at them
the whole time is a combination of
direct gaze averting gaze and closing
one's eyes that's you know a real
conversation involves moments where
you're looking away trying to cr you
know
like i'm doing right now i'm trying to
you know grab a concept and say it uh in
a way that makes sense but then also
where we re-engage and so a conversation
is actually a process of of looking
directly at the other person and then
breaking gays and then coming back again
the other thing that works quite well if
people are experiencing eye fatigue
from looking at screens up close and
there's a whole other conversation
is
one thing that works well is to see
someone's face at the beginning say
hello because faces are a powerful um
you know they it collects a lot of
context for the brain saying hello but
then going into pure audio and then
going back to visual before you part
ways that may actually be a more
effective form of zoom communication
than pretending we're all in the same
room and trying to stare at one another
the entire time and sometimes see that
reflection of ourselves and that's
that's advice that that others on this
podcast have given that that you don't
have to show your video the whole time
so before we end andrew i'd like to ask
you the same three questions i ask
everybody who joins me on this podcast
are you up for that
definitely
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
be
speak to
inform
and teach
not impress
oh i like that so it's about getting the
information across and you are certainly
a master at that and i encourage
everybody to search out some of the work
you've done your podcast is fantastic
because you do such a nice job of
something we talked about on an earlier
podcast how to make complex information
accessible you do a great job of that
you certainly don't dumb it down but you
make it accessible as you've done for us
today let me ask question number two who
is a communication that you admire and
why
you know i
they're two forms of communication that
really appeal to me and they will seem
at
odds with one another uh
i love poetry
because
really great poetry
doesn't really make sense at a
uh cognitive level it gets to a
kind of what probably is some sort of
deeper universal meaning it probably is
tapping into
brain circuits that are more on a
emotional level or that
reside in the brain body connection i
really believe that so that speaks to
some sort of quote unquote truth
um so i love poetry and
um
i'm a big wendell berry fan i'm also a
big joe strummer fan you know uh most
famous for being the singer of the clash
for the things he said not while he was
on stage so joe strummer on uh was
brilliant uh
in terms of his um
offstage speech
encourage people to check out some of
the things that joe said later in his
life were really remarkable insights
into human beings and humanity there's
some real core truth there
and
the in the world of science
claude despond is a
biology professor at nyu who studies
insect
vision
and
the only word that i can use to describe
what it is to hear one of claude's
lecture whether or not you're familiar
with biology or not is pure enchantment
wow
he transports you into a world where
frankly i i don't really care about
dragonfly vision on a regular basis but
when i listen to claude speak i think
about human vision i think about
uh love he talks about the love spots of
the dragonfly eyes that for pursuing uh
mates and food and it's just remarkable
and anyone that can
do that um for is
incredible but claude is the uh world
heavyweight champion of making biology
inc fascinating and uh delightful well
i'm gonna check his lectures out for
sure last question for you what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
passion
the speaker has to love the topic
in organizational logic there has to be
a
structure
to
the information it it just can't be
bullet points and a beginning middle end
kind of thing
and
clarity you know if people
if people walk away understanding more
than they did at the beginning
then you you won
it gets back to the the most important
thing to do is to teach your audience
educate them
passion structure and clarity psc we're
going to add that as another acronym to
your list of many acronyms i've heard
you talk about andrew it was fantastic
to have you here i'm taking a deep
breath to calm myself down from all the
exciting information that you shared
thank you so much it is my true hope
that all of us listening in can apply
some of these tools and hacks to
optimize our communication thank you
thanks so much for having me
thank you for listening to think fast
talk smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business to
learn more go to gsb.stanford.edu
please download other episodes wherever
you find your podcasts